Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Frau Schäker.
Ich bin auf der Station als Assistent-Arzt in Petik.
Heute möchte ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschritt durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, mir ist guckt jemand nach mir. Ja klar.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Peter Lindemann.
Peter Lindemann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname buchstabieren?
Ja, das ist L-I-N-G-E-M-A-N.
Okay.
Lindemann.
Hi, Lindemann. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 23. März 54.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich kann Sie ganz schlecht verstehen gerade.
Moment. Es ist ganz leise.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege noch 74 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
Okay. Herr Peter, was fühlt Sie uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, mir geht es eigentlich schon seit längerer Zeit nicht so besonders gut.
Und ich habe auch, also eigentlich schon länger so Bauchschmerzen.
Aber jetzt heute Morgen war, was mir wirklich ein bisschen schreckend eingejagt hat.
Ich hatte so ganz dunklen Stuhl, das war ganz schwarz.
Und ja, da habe ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal zum Arzt gehen.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, also so richtig Bauchschmerzen, vielleicht so seit 2 Wochen, dass ich das so richtig merke.
Aber ich habe schon längere Zeit so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Verdauung.
Mal habe ich Durchfall und dann habe ich tagelang keinen Stuhlgang.
Und denke ich schon, oh je, was ist jetzt los.
Und ja, und ich fühle mich auch eigentlich ziemlich schlapp.
Und dann habe ich jetzt gedacht, als das mit diesem komischen schwarzen Stuhlgang da heute Morgen war.
Jetzt muss ich aber mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Haben Sie ein ungewöhnliches Geräusch gemerkt?
Im Stuhlgang?
Was habe ich gemerkt?
Eine unangenehme Geräusch.
Sie mal ein Geruch?
Geruch, ja.
Das riecht ja immer schlecht, aber ich würde nicht sagen, nicht anders als sonst.
Okay. Leider, dass Sie unter Übel kannst heute?
Ja, so richtig übel würde ich jetzt sagen, nicht.
Aber bestimmte Sachen mag ich zurzeit überhaupt nicht mehr essen.
Und tatsächlich hatte ich neulich auch mal, also vor wenigen Tagen, habe ich mich übergeben müssen.
Eigentlich so aus halterem Himmel.
Da war mir vorher gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber mit einem Mal habe ich dann gedacht, oh jetzt muss ich aber, oh, jetzt muss ich spucken
und muss schnell auf die Toilette gehen und mich übergeben.
Das kenne ich eigentlich sonst gar nicht.
Mussten Sie nur einmal übergeben?
Zwei Mal ist das gewesen.
Ich möchte über Ihre Bauchschmerzen etwas fragen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
um zu beschweren, zu bewerben oder zu bewerben?
Also eher drückend und vielleicht eher krampfartig als stechend.
Haben diese Schmerzen Plutz nicht begonnen vor zwei Wochen oder eher langsam?
Ja, also wie gesagt so ganz gut habe ich mich schon lange nicht gefühlt.
Aber dann hatte ich erst so ein leichtes Drücken und das ist aber immer mehr geworden, ja.
Ich zeige dann, wie Schmerzen irgendein Tor hinaus?
Ja, also das ist hier so oben im Bauch und ja, das führt dazu,
dass ich mich im ganzen Bauchbereich eigentlich schlecht fühle.
Aber eigentlich ist es mehr so oben im Bauch.
Sind diese Schmerzen am stärksten oben im Bauch?
Ja.
Genau, tut weh, oben im Bauch.
Rechts oder links?
Eigentlich würde ich sagen in der Mitte.
Mitte, okay.
Kennen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Hatten Sie für Hall schon einmal?
Ja, also jeder hat mal irgendwie so ein bisschen Wagenschmerzen
oder auch Bauchschmerzen, wenn man mal Durchfall hat oder so.
Aber dass das so lang anhalten ist und auch immer schlechter wird,
das kenne ich eigentlich nicht so.
Hatten Sie schon einmal diese Dunklerstour oder erst einmal?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich das schon mal hatte.
Hatten Sie, wie man es gibt, eine bestimmte Auslösung für Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind jetzt ja dauerhaft.
Also da würde ich sagen, da kann ich nichts ausmachen,
womit das angefangen hat oder so.
Mit einmal habe ich das gemerkt, dass dieser Druck eben dauerhaft ist
und ich habe das Gefühl, dass es immer schlechter wird.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 bereiten,
wenn Eis kaum Schmerzen sind und 10 starker Schmerzen bedeutet?
Stärkste Schmerzen sind es nicht.
Also ich würde vielleicht so in der Mitte sagen.
Ich merke, dass da nichts, dass da was ist und das mich das stört,
aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass ich da seit Tagen irgendwie völlig kaubend vor Schmerzen.
Ich fühle mich eher anderweitig schlapp und kraftlos.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen auch in Ruhe?
Nein, nicht ständig.
Ja, oft kann ich nachts nicht gut schlafen, weil ich das Gefühl habe,
der Bauch drückt irgendwie, das tut weh.
Haben Sie gestern etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Nein, ich meine zurzeit schmeckt es mir sowieso die ganze Zeit nicht so besonders gut,
aber ich habe ganz normal gegessen.
Ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen, dass da irgendwas war, was ich sonst nicht esse.
Hat er Sie einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall?
Ja.
Nein, ein Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerden, die dann Bauchschmerzen oder diese Sturz?
Ja, also dass ich mich so schlapp fühle, dass ich so, dass mir das Essen nicht schmeckt
und dass ich mich halt so kraftlos fühle.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen,
aber glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Nachtscheiß?
Ja, also manchmal schwitze ich schon in der Nacht
und ich kann auch nicht gut durchschlafen.
Ich wache also oft in der Nacht auf
und ich meine sowieso muss ich zweimal mindestens auf die Toilette gehen nachts.
Aber...
Was ist das?
Ja.
Haben Sie in der Leicesterarbeit abgenommen?
Ja, also ich habe ordentlich abgenommen.
Meine Hosen sind mir alle zu weit
und meine Wintersachen schlottern alle.
Ich habe fast 10 kg abgenommen im letzten halben Jahr.
Ja, okay.
In den sechs Monaten 10 kg abgenommen.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig?
Ja.
Schwindelig ist mir eigentlich normal nicht nö.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie müssten nachts
zweimal auf die Toilette gehen,
aber gibt es eine andere Wasserlassensprobleme?
Nö, normal.
Ich muss halt nur nachts immer noch einmal laufen, ja.
Aber sonst gibt es eigentlich keine Probleme.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihre Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also das, was alle haben, nicht in meinem Alter.
Ich habe ein bisschen Arthrose in den Kniegelenken
und in den Hüftgelenken
und ich habe auch ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck.
Das hat man vor fünf Jahren festgestellt
und ich habe schon lange so ein Diabetes.
Insofern fand ich das ganz praktisch,
dass ich ein bisschen abgenommen habe.
Ich nehme Metformin regelmäßig
und mein Haus guckt eigentlich auch immer mal wieder
nach den Zuckerwerten, aber da war ich jetzt auch länger nicht.
Leiden Sie an Diabetes?
Ja, das hat man so vor 15 Jahren ungefähr festgestellt.
Aber das war nie so ausgeprägt.
Ich bin immer mit dem Metformin, morgens bin ich immer hingekommen.
Ich musste nie irgendwie mehr Tabletten nehmen.
Nehmen Sie einen Metformin?
Ich nehme jeden Morgen eine Tablette
und, oh, was steht da drauf?
Ich glaube, 800 steht da drauf.
Nehmen Sie eine andere Metformin?
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe in den Knien
oder wenn es mir beim Laufen so wie tut,
dann nehme ich wohl mal Ibuprofen.
Aber nur, wenn ich große Beschwerden habe.
Wie viele Milligrammen nehmen Sie Ibuprofen ein?
Ja, so. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich glaube, da steht 600 auf der Packung drauf.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind natürlich, sind mir die Mandeln rausgenommen worden.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich noch keine große Operation hinter mir.
Ja, verliehen Sie, nehmen Sie, guckt du einen Metformin?
Warten Sie, ich kann Sie nicht verstehen gerade.
Entschuldigung, nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck ein Medikamenten?
Ja, ich habe dann meine Zeit ein Rami-Pril genommen,
aber das habe ich dann nicht gut vertragen
und dann habe ich das einfach weggelassen.
Und so hoch ist der jetzt nicht.
Also aktuell nehme ich das nicht.
Okay, messen Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Ja, also manchmal gehe ich in die Apotheke und lasse da messen.
Und beim Hausarzt, wenn ich dahin gehe, dann misst der Aufmal,
aber ich messe nicht regelmäßig.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Allergie oder Unweiligkeit?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich, was, dass ich ein Medikament,
ein Schmerzmedikament nicht vertragen kann.
Und zwar nur Valginen.
Das darf ich nicht nehmen.
Ich habe es nicht, also so Pickel auf der Haut und das Juckt.
Und außerdem hat man auch festgestellt, dass ich eine Jodallergie habe.
Und da darf ich halt keine jodhaltigen Sachen benutzen.
Okay.
Und, dann lehnt man da für Sie?
Ja, also ich rauche längst nicht mehr so viel.
Ich habe nur noch 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Früher habe ich viele, viele Jahre das Doppelte geraucht.
Aber ja, doch 10 Zigaretten am Tag rauche ich noch.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ach schon, ewig.
Da hatte ich erwachsen bin.
Also würde sagen, die letzten 10 Jahre rauche ich nicht mehr so viel.
Aber vorher habe ich bestimmt 35 Jahre lang ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Seit 10 Jahren rauchen Sie nur 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Ja, genau.
Und in den letzten Tagen hatte ich mir auch nicht so gut geschmeckt, muss ich sagen.
Tränken Sie Alkohol?
Na ja, also Alkohol, ja.
Also ich trinke 2 Flaschen Bier am Abend und ja, manchmal auch noch ein Schnaps.
Je nachdem, aber den Schnaps habe ich jetzt in den letzten Tagen auch weggelassen.
Ich habe es mir nicht so gut geschmeckt.
Aber doch ansonsten trinke ich das schon ziemlich regelmäßig.
Die nächste Frage ist eine standarte Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ich?
Nein, also Drogen nehme ich nun wirklich nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihre Familie geschütze und Familie Stand fragen.
Bleiben Sie Ihre Eltern?
Ob meine Eltern noch leben?
Ja.
Ne, die sind beide früh gestorben.
Mein Vater ist früh gestorben, der hatte eine Darmkrebserkrankung
und ist mit 65 gestorben.
Meine Mutter, die war ohnehin schon sehr depressiv.
Und als sie dann alleine war, da hat sie sich, also auch da war sie dann 65,
da hat sie sich das Leben genommen.
Da hat sie Tabletten genommen und konnte nicht mehr gerettet werden.
Ja, das war ganz schlimm.
Tut mir sehr leid.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister hatte ich nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon erwachsen.
Die haben schon selber Kinder, ja.
Und wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe zwei Kinder gehabt.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder?
Ja.
Okay. Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Ehre?
Mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja, ja, genau.
Was haben Sie früher von beruflich gemacht?
Ich war viele Jahre Automechaniker,
habe in der großen Autowerkstatt in der Stadt gearbeitet.
Und treiben Sie Sport heutzutage?
Nein, da bin ich ein bisschen zu faul dazu.
Ich bin früher mal gerne Fahrrad gefahren und schwimmen gegangen.
Aber die letzten Jahre habe ich eigentlich keinen Sport gemacht.
Okay.
Unser Geschwister ist fast vorgeweiht.
Haben Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt schon so viel erzählt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich noch irgendwas vergessen habe.
Aber ich will jetzt natürlich wissen, was da los ist,
was mit dem Bauch ist, warum das so schrecklich aussieht,
dieser Stuhlgang da und woher das kommen kann.
Und natürlich habe ich auch ein bisschen Sorge,
weil mein Vater eben am Krebs gestorben ist,
ob ich vielleicht auch irgendwas im Darm habe oder so.
Das möchte ich halt ganz gerne jetzt schon wissen.
Ja, das verstehe ich genau.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorge.
Es ist jetzt so für eine Diagnose festzustellen.
Wir werden ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wenn alle Ergebnisse da sind, können wir klare Diagnose stellen.
Ich werde Ihnen alle Schritt für Schritt erklären.
Muss ich denn jetzt hier bleiben?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich muss auch im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Wenn alle Ergebnisse da sind, müssen Sie hier bleiben.
Dann werden wir wieder sprechen.
Ah, okay, gut.
Sind Sie damit zufrieden?
Ja, ja.
Was wird jetzt als nächstes gemacht?
So heißt würde ich Sie Köpfe untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Röntgenbau und Ultraschall durchführen.
Außerdem ist eine Labor-Untersuchung erforderlich.
Deshalb würde ich Ihnen ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, klar.
Sie müssen sich ja entscheiden.
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Okay, dann warte ich hier.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Hatten Sie schon einmal eine Endoscopy?
Ah, gute Frage.
Nee, hatte er noch nicht.
Danke schön.
Leiden Sie unter Herz-Rasen oder Herzklopfen?
Herzklopfen? Nein, Bauchschmerzen habe ich, aber kein Herzklopfen.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
In letzter Zeit hat sich Ihre Haut oder Augen merklich gelblich geworden?
Ob es eine Farbveränderung gegeben hat, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
So meine Frau hat auch nichts gesagt.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Hat sie ja gefragt, habe ich verneint außer dass ich eben 2-3 mal nachts auf die Toilette muss.
Aber es ist keine Probleme.
Meine Frage ist, wie euch sich ihr Wasserlassen hat?
Das sieht ganz normal aus. Ich muss nur häufiger gehen.
Sie haben gesagt, lange seid Bauchschmerzen haben.
Genau, wie viel?
Nein, er hat nicht gesagt, die Bauchschmerzen hat er eigentlich seit 2 Wochen.
Aber er fühlt sich schon länger schlecht.
Er fühlt sich schon länger schlapp und ist Essen schmeckt nicht und er ist ein bisschen müde.
Im Stadus hat sie nicht gefragt, aber ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft.
Hepatitis A oder B haben Sie schon gemacht.
Würste ich jetzt nicht, habe ich nie etwas gehabt.
Danke schön. Das waren meine Fragen.
Herr Lindemann, strahlen die Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion aus?
Sie strahlen nicht aus, sie sind auf den Oberbauch beschränkt.
Das hat die Kollegen aber auch schon ziemlich am Anfang gefragt.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind im Oberbauch.
Sie haben schon gesagt, vor 2 Wochen leiden Sie unter diesen Schmerzen.
Waren Sie schon einmal Hausarzt?
Nein, beim Hausarzt war ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Herr Lindemann, leiden Sie unter Aufstossen oder Sortbrennen oder volle Gefühle nach dem Essen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist mir noch nie, auch wenn ich etwas ganz Scharfes mal esse,
dann habe ich das wohl mal, dass ich ein bisschen aufstoßen muss, aber normalerweise nicht.
Okay, also ich sehe Ihnen schon ein Magingeschwür oder Acetis bekannt.
Nein, da habe ich bisher noch nie Probleme mit gehabt.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, Magingeschmerzen, manchmal gibt es.
Ja, jeder hat mal Magingeschmerzen in seinem Leben.
Aber ich habe noch nie einen Magingeschwür gehabt.
Okay, danke.
Herr Lindemann, Sie müssten sich 2-mal übergeben.
Wie sah das Erbrochen aus?
Das waren Essenreste, aber das sah auch ein bisschen dunkelkommisch aus.
So ein bisschen schwarz-grün, so dunkelbraunen Krümelig sah das aus.
Es sah eigentlich unappetitlich aus.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie für diese Beschwerdenmedikamente eingenommen?
Nein, da habe ich jetzt nichts genommen.
Ich habe versucht, einen Schnaps zu trinken, aber das hat es auch nicht besser gemacht.
Dann habe ich den Schnaps lieber weggelassen.
Aber irgendwelche Medikamente habe ich nicht genommen.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind geschafft.
Können wir Arsatzgeschichte anfangen?
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe keine Stimmung.
Entschuldigung.
Können wir starten?
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe keine Stimmung.
Ich weiß.
Natürlich.
Wie haben Sie gesehen?
Unser Patient heißt Peter Lindemann.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,79 Meter groß und 74 Kilogramm.
Er kann uns heute Morgen aufgetretener
dunkler Stur.
Diese Stur sieht wie Melana.
Und Herr Lindemann berichtete,
er habe seit 2 Wochen Abdominalschmerzen.
Diese Schmerzen sind im Ganze,
ganz, ganz, ganz,
ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz Baum,
ganz Baumstrahlen,
aber die Zentrum ist Epigast,
Epigasträl-Bereich.
Ja, die Schmerzen haben
ziemlich langsam begonnen
und sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlägt.
Was, wann,
hat ihr die Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich Erschmerzen.
Der Schmerzinteresse liegt auf einer Schmerzskalabine,
in der Mitte, und er fülle sich müde und kraftlos.
Er musste zweimal erbrechen.
Er musste zusätzlich durch eine Durchlaustörung nachdurch
zweimal auf die Toilette, d.h. Nüctrie,
und er klagte über Inapätenz in dieser Seite.
Er habe kein Fieber, aber in der sechs Monate
habe er 10 kg abgenommen.
Er ist ein Erdbeer, der seit fünf Jahren
Arterial-Hypertonie und Diabetes-Militus
seit 15 Jahren bekannt.
Er nimmt gegen Diabetes-Militus mit Formen
800 mg morgens ein.
Er nimmt Ibuprofen by Bedarf ein, 600 mg.
Früher habe er Ramipril eingenommen,
aber jetzt habe er weg gelassen.
Und ihre Blutdruck habe er nicht regelmäßig gemessen.
Er ist ein allergescher Erdbeer, der seit fünf Jahren
auf die Toilette und die Toilette.
auf die Toilette.
Er ist seit vier Jahren lang Raucher,
aber seit zehn Jahren ein Taigli-Sens-Sigarette,
aber seit 35 Jahren ein Taigli-Einschatter.
Er trinkt zwei Flaschen abends.
Bei der Familienanalyse ergab sich Folgendes.
Sein Vater ist am Kolonkarstnern mit 65 Jahre verstorben.
Seine Mutter liebt an Depressionen.
Sie ist mit 65 wegen Suicide verstopf.
Er ist ein Selkind, habe kein Geschwister.
Er ist verheiratet, habe Sivalkind und sei gesund.
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau.
Jetzt ist er fremdnerin, aber früher war er fremdner.
Aber früher war er Automekaniker.
Heute Tage treibe er nichts Sport.
Und das war alles.
Was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Meine Verteidigung, er lautet Kolonkarstnern.
Ich habe Familienrisiko.
Die Melena ist eine große Seiche.
Ich habe eine gewichtsweilige Symptome.
Was könnte das Differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Differenzial diagnostisch kommt Gastrodöne und Kusskrankheit.
Was ist das noch?
Oberbauschmerzen?
Magenkerl.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wo rauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Die digitalen Rektaluntersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Ist das Melena oder nicht?
Und Abdomen, Perkistion, Inspektion sind sehr wichtig.
Ich kontrolliere die Vitalparameter.
Blutdruck könnte niedrig sein.
Dann nehme ich den Patienten stationär auf.
Laboruntersuchung ist erforderlich.
Was lassen Sie labordiaglastisch untersuchen?
Blutbild, Erzündung, CRP, BCG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte,
Leberhaus, Amylars, Kohlestagswerte, Elektrolyte.
Studiagnostik ist sehr wichtig.
Was machen Sie noch?
Abdomensonografie ist wichtig.
Und Röntgen.
Was würden Sie röntgen?
Röntgen, Abdomen.
Dann gegebenfalls aber Kuloscopy.
Was würde man sonst noch machen?
Wie bitte?
Wenn man den Oberbauch in den Fokus nimmt,
dann würde man zusätzlich zur Kuloscopy machen.
Ich frage mich, ob ich eine Kuloscopy mache.
Ja, genau.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
das bei Herrn Lindemann rauskommt.
Dann schauen wir mal, was da dahinter steckt.
Dann hoffen wir, dass es ihm bald wieder besser geht.
Gut, alles klar.
War er wirklich Erster an einem Nese?
Nein.
Letzter Woche habe ich nur eine andere Gäste.
Das war es weiter.
Sie haben das eigentlich schön gemacht.
Manchmal haben Sie ein bisschen lange gezögert.
Ah, genau.
Tu-Mau-Marca sagt jemanden für Laborwerte.
Manchmal hat das ein bisschen länger gebraucht,
bis Sie die nächste Frage gestellt haben.
War vielleicht auch ein bisschen technisches Problem.
Was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat,
dass Sie auf diese Inappetenz
und Wiederwillen gegen Lebensmittel,
dass Sie auf diese subjektiven Sachen,
da haben Sie nicht viel nachgefragt.
Da sind Sie nicht sehr darauf eingegangen.
Haben das eigentlich auch nicht so sehr weitergegeben.
Er hat am Anfang auch gesagt,
diesen Wechsel von Durchfall und Verstopfung.
Das haben Sie jetzt auch nicht weiter erwähnt.
Aber sonst ist alles gekommen.
Manchmal gab es sprachlich so ganz,
auf den Blick,
das ist so ganz nebenbei so eine Formulierung gewesen.
Die Allergie gegen Novagin äußert sich mit Hautausschlag.
Da haben Sie nur äußert sich mit.
Ansonsten war es aber in der Fragestellung ziemlich komplett.
Auch im Bericht haben Sie sehr vollständig wiedergegeben,
was der Patient Ihnen erzählt hat.
Da gibt es eigentlich keine Reclamation,
würde ich jetzt mal sagen.
Ihnen ist auch jede Menge eingefallen,
was man diagnostisch mit den Patienten macht.
Tatsächlich hatte der hier jetzt
einen Magenkazinum,
keinen Digtumkazinum.
Vielleicht wegen der Manifestation der Schmerzen
im Oberbauch könnte man da so ein bisschen drauf kommen.
Auch beim Digtarm ist ja Melena nicht unbedingt das Problem.
Da wäre dann eher frisches Blut.
Es ist offensichtlich verdauetes Blut.
Das hat allerdings ein Kollege gefragt,
und ich sehe, wie das Erbrochene aussah.
Das wäre ein ziemlich eindeutiger Indikator.
Da hat er ja beschrieben, dass er der Altesblut erbrochen hat.
Damit wäre man so ein bisschen auf der richtigen Pferde.
Diagnostisch würden Sie das auf alle Fälle rauskriegen
im Zusammenhang mit der Sonografie,
oder mit der ÖGD.
Ich glaube, Sie können sehr zufrieden sein.
Haben Sie das gut gemacht?
Wissen Sie sich schon, wenn Sie Prüfung machen?
Ja, am 20. Juni.